okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine to david p
yesterday on the bonus show i told a
story about catching a dog owner letting
their dog do their serious business on
the front lawn of my condo it's a small
condo a contrary to what the Eggman
seems to think in this voicemail that he
left but he is poop shaming my he rather
he is shaming me for poop shaming a dog
owner take a listen to this hi dave
welcome back i think your assessment of
italy verb france was relatively correct
thank you there's less money in italy
they're not doing so well right now it's
not like it's a respect and they're just
poor i have family that lives there and
um no one knew that i know anyway he's
doing great but um
dave what the heck do you want the guy
to do with this dog poop and in front of
your condo okay first of all you don't
the inside of your condo not the outside
is common so everybody else right so I
assume this guy's did not speak on to
your condo property from somewhere else
we must live there your community also
he doesn't look he picked up the poop
and he put it in the garbage
what do you want him to put in his
pocket and carry it around with him I
knew this guy was a responsible dog
owner but what this knows about you is
that you just have no empathy for people
or animals Oh plant his dog man and pick
up some poop and then you'll feel you
know what this guy feels he did a good
job
so don't cook shame him you know like he
were contained in the restaurant with
your stinky zoo welcome back brother
Ferran and bendixson both did really
really good jobs sorrow about yeah so I
mean a lot of what the Eggman is saying
there is based on things that are not
accurate so the best response I think is
listen to yesterday's bonus show there
is the poop shaming story there is the
Italian taxi driver story people abuzz
and extremely titillated by the stories
I told yesterday on the bonus show so
get access to membership become a member
rather to get access to the bonus show
you will hear all of those stories today
but today's bonus show we'll talk about
the Supreme Court
word decision about Indiana's abortion
law we'll talk about a mass stabbing in
Japan we'll talk about the activist
built us-mexico border wall and much
much more
ww join pakman.com coupon code this is
20/20
saves you 40% but you still get all of
the benefits